[Applause]
an extraordinarily tight race The
center-right People's Party leader
Alberto fejjar may have emerged as the
candidate with the most votes but it was
still too short of a majority for his
party to govern outright Amigos
friends we have won the elections we now
need to try to form a government as has
always happened under Spanish democracy
yet for the party supporters a win
nonetheless
clear if Mr feijo will be able to form a
government
it's still not enough seats for an
outright Majority vox's Leader Santiago
abascal has turned the party into the
third largest electoral force in the
country it is a party that is stridently
anti-immigration it has also promised to
roll back spending and policies that the
socialist-led government have put into
place that combat climate change and
protect minorities
as for the Prime Minister the man who
called the snap election
there are many more of us who want Spain
to continue moving forward than pursuing
the regressive path of the People's
Party
Chris that for now failed to pay off it
paved the way for a possible far-right
presence in the government not seen
since Spain's return to democracy in the
1970s Sonia Gallego Al Jazeera Madrid
Pablo caldero Martinez is from the
Northeastern University in London he
says the left-wing Coalition can be
happy with the result
uh to be honest I'm surprised in the
sense that I think uh the left has
slightly over performed to what most of
the polls suggested I think the the
Socialist Camp is probably going to be
at these early stages at least the
happier of the two uh I think it was a
further conclusion that the part of
popular was going to be the largest
party in Congress that was always seemed
to be the case but it seems like they're
gonna fall just shy of being able to
form a a majority even in uh some sort
of Coalition with the Vox party so there
is still a chance that the federal
Sanchez may find a way of keeping power
and keeping a broader Coalition that
will keep the socials in power so I
think the the Socialist Party has over
performed slightly and I think that the
right-wing block has perhaps
underperformed which means that I'm
pretty much having a very much divided
country and 50 50 which is is going to
be interesting to see how we maneuver
how negotiate the the next government
the Box part is is successfully doing is
perhaps pulling the the conservative
body the popular policy a little bit
more to the right and they've been very
successful to a great extent in making
this election about what they wanted
this election to be which is cultural
issues uh climate change social problems
social issues economically speaking and
the economy has been relatively good in
Spain over the last four years and
that's the strong part of the socialist
government but I don't think they've
been able to really make the selection
about the economy and it's been more
about cultural rewards really and that
has benefited the right and slightly
more